Speaker 1: One other Herschel Walker story.
I have a clip of Marjorie Taylor GREENE,
radical Republican Congresswoman Marjorie
Taylor GREENE who represents the state
of Georgia, after all, in the House of
Representatives. She even is admitting.
Asking people to vote for Herschel Walker.
That's asking a lot. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 4: We really need Georgia to get out
and vote for Herschel Walker. Please do it. And
I know I know we're asking a lot of you, but we
need you. Get out there and vote. There is a lot
more to what it looks like than just a Republican
and a Democrat. This is the future of our country.
This is the future for our children. And it. It's
also the way your money is spent in Washington. So
I'm asking you to get out and vote for my friend
Herschel Walker and of course, fellow UGA Bulldog.
We're always so proud. Of course, our football
team in the years that he played there. And
it would just be wonderful. It'd be great
to have a dog up there in the Senate. Dog?
Speaker 2: Yeah.
Speaker 1: She's all but saying to Republicans,
listen, you've got to hold your nose and vote
for Walker to block Raphael Warnock from being
a member of the Senate. Someone wrote to me and
they said, David, do you think Marjorie Taylor
GREENE means that it's a lot to ask to vote for
Walker because Walker's a bad candidate or because
Walker is black? And I thought that's a very low
blow. We have no actual evidence that that's what
Marjorie Taylor GREENE meant. Let's not even
go there. But it is a theme that even some
of the wackiest Republicans and without a doubt,
Marjorie Taylor GREENE qualifies as one of those.
Some of the wackiest Republicans seem to recognize
this entire Herschel Walker thing. It's not a
particularly good idea. And so step one is we've
got to get through tomorrow. Hopefully Raphael
Warnock is voted, wins and stays in the Senate
and Herschel Walker is gone and we never hear from
him again in a political space. He can go back to
doing whatever else he wants to do. The next step
is, have Republicans learned in a sense that it
wasn't a great idea to run these wacky candidates
and that Trump's endorsement alone doesn't seem
to be enough to get some of them past the finish
line. We saw it with German Jew ski. We saw it
with John Gibbs, we saw it with Doug Mastriano.
We saw it with Mehmet Oz. We're hopefully going
to see it with Herschel Walker. Will they learn?
And if so, is that actually worse for Democrats
in the sense that they might nominate people
more likely to win? That's a story for
later in the next 24 hours. Vote, vote,
vote. We're going to take a quick break.
Make sure you're subscribed on YouTube at
YouTube.com slash The David Pakman Show. Just a
reminder, if I sound weird, I have COVID. I had
a brutal 30 hours of fever over the weekend
during which I watched World Cup and watched
oh, I watched the new Argentinean film, 1985
about the prosecution of those at the head of
the military dictatorship in Argentina in the
late seventies. Very, very good film. And then,
like a Phenix rising over the horizon,
my fever cleared and now I have a cold.
But I am here and that is what matters.
Okay, quick break. Back right after this